mais aussi une réduction de gabarit.
Le nombre d'enfants de moins de 5 ans présentant un retard de croissance,
à travers le monde,
est en train de diminuer.
Et je déteste dire ça,
mais le seul endroit où le nombre ne faiblit pas est ici,
en Afrique.
Ici, 59 millions d'enfants,
3 sur 10 dans ce groupe d'âge,
ne parviennent pas à atteindre leur potentiel génétique,
leur plein potentiel génétique.
Les protéines sont primordiales dans notre alimentation
et des preuves montrent qu'un manque d'acides aminés,
composants des protéines, dans l'alimentation des enfants
crée un retard de croissance.
Les acides aminés sont dits essentiels
car on ne peut pas les synthétiser dans le corps.
Seule la nourriture en contient
et la meilleure source de ces acides est d'origine animale :
le lait, la viande et les œufs.
La plupart des protéines consommées en Afrique est végétale.
Et même s'il existe des millions de petits éleveurs,
la production de bétail n'est pas aussi simple qu'on le pense.
L'écart de production de bétail entre les pays riches et les pays pauvres
est dû à la santé des animaux.
Les malades endémiques du bétail,
dont certaines transmissibles à l'homme,
ne menacent pas seulement la santé des producteurs dans les pays pauvres,
mais aussi la santé du reste du monde.
C'est un réseau d'agents pathogènes.
Ceci montre les agents pathogènes trouvés sur Terre
d'après la base de données des maladies infectieuses.
Ça révèle que ces agents pathogènes partagent les mêmes hôtes.
En gros,
on partage des agents pathogènes, donc des maladies,
avec les espèces qui vivent au plus près de nous :
le bétail.
On les appelle les maladies zoonotiques.
Des rapports récents montrent
que les 12 maladies d'origine animale tuent 2,2 millions de personnes
et contaminent 2,4 milliards de personnes chaque année.
Et Jimmy dit :
« La grande majorité du fardeau des zoonoses
tombe sur un milliard de petits éleveurs pauvres. »
On sous-estime l'importance de nos petits agriculteurs.
On commence à admettre combien ils sont importants
et combien ils influencent notre santé,
notre biosécurité
et plus récemment, notre santé cognitive et physique.
Ils sont en première ligne pour les épidémies zoonotiques.
Ils étayent notre existence en quelque sorte.
Ils ont besoin de savoir tellement de choses
mais la plupart d'entre eux manquent de connaissances
sur la prévention et le traitement des maladies du bétail.
Alors comment apprennent-ils ?
En dehors du partage d'expérience,
des essais et des erreurs,
les services de vulgarisation agricole sur le terrain et à la radio
sont chers et difficiles à développer face à la croissance démographique.
Inquiétant, n'est-ce pas ?
Mais on en est à un stade intéressant en Afrique.
On change le cours de l'histoire en déployant des mesures innovantes,
en exploitant des technologies évolutives.
Le savoir n'a pas besoin d'être hors de prix.
Mon entreprise a développé une plateforme agricole appelée iCow.
On apprend aux éleveurs les meilleures pratiques à exercer
par SMS, avec de simples téléphones.
Les éleveurs reçoivent 3 SMS par semaine avec des conseils
et ceux qui les suivent observent une augmentation de leur productivité
dans un délai de trois mois.
Les premières hausses de productivité améliorent la santé des animaux.
On utilise les SMS car c'est simple.
Les éleveurs gardent leurs messages,
les écrivent dans un livre
et petit à petit,
des manuels agricoles jaillissent dans les champs.
On constate qu'on fait tous partie du réseau mondial de l'alimentation :
producteurs et consommateurs,
vous et moi, ainsi que chaque agriculteur.
On essaie maintenant de rassembler les producteurs et consommateurs
pour agir et être responsables de la sécurité alimentaire
et de la salubrité alimentaire.
Cette vache afro-asiatique est croisée avec un fleckvieh néerlandais.
Elle fait plus de lait que sa mère pakistanaise
et elle est plus robuste et résistante aux maladies que son père fleckvieh.
En Éthiopie et en Tanzanie,
le programme africain de gains génétiques pour les produits laitiers
fait usage de SMS et de génomique de pointe
et est précurseur des premiers centres africains
d'espèces laitières tropicales adaptées
et des centres de contrôle de rendement des produits laitiers.
Les éleveurs partagent leurs données de production --
le lait produit,
l'élevage et l'alimentation produite --
sur la plateforme du programme.
Cette étape est synthétisée par les algorithmes
des meilleures institutions de bétail du monde
avant de revenir entre les mains de l'éleveur
sous forme de SMS.
Des données personnalisées,
des réponses adaptées,
tout cela pour augmenter la productivité
d'après le potentiel sur place.
On est à un point intéressant dans le domaine agricole en Afrique.
D'ici la fin de l'année,
on aura presque atteint le milliard d'abonnements téléphoniques.
Nous avons entre nos mains le pouvoir
de nous assurer que les systèmes de production de bétail sont sains,
productifs et rentables,
mais aussi que les éleveurs sont informés
et plus important encore,
que nos éleveurs sont en sécurité.
Travailler avec des petits éleveurs
est un des meilleurs moyens de garantir la sécurité alimentaire.
C'est aussi l'une des meilleures façons
de donner à chaque enfant l'opportunité
et la capacité d'atteindre son plein potentiel génétique.
Et en exploitant le pouvoir de millions de petits éleveurs
ainsi que de leurs superbes vaches,
on devrait pouvoir mettre un terme au retard de croissance en Afrique.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)